we're asked which two of the following
expressions have the same value as eight
point seven six pause this video and see
if you can figure this out on your own
alright now let's do it together and
before I even look at these choices I'm
just going to really understand what
this number represents and let me just
rewrite it so we have eight point seven
six so there's a couple of ways that we
could think about it we can look at our
place values this right over here this
is the ones place this right over here
this is the tenths place and this right
over here is the hundreds hundreds place
and so we could view this as eight ones
and seven tenths and six hundredths or
eight ones plus seven tenths plus six
hundredths well that's exactly what they
wrote right over here eight ones seven
tenths and six hundredths so I would
choose that one for sure now this second
choice looks like an expanded form but
before I even look at it let's see how
we would think about it over here if we
wanted to essentially write the same
idea but in expanded form eight ones is
the same thing as eight times one and
actually let me color code it so you see
where things are coming from so eight
ones that's the same thing as 8 times
one and two that we would add seven
tenths so that's plus seven times 1/10
so seven tenths plus and I'll do this in
this orange color six hundredths so
that's plus six times a hundred six
hundredths so this would be this number
in expanded form is that what they put
right over here yes it is indeed what
they put right over here so I will
circle that in now if you're doing this
on your own we know that we just picked
two answers but let's see these whether
these other forms or let's see if we can
write this in these other forms and see
how these might not be the exact answer
so if we were to if we were to write
this out and take out each of the
decimal parts so the eight ones you
would just write that as eight the seven
tenths seven tenths
that would be plus 0.7 this is seven
tenths right over here this and this and
this part right over here are all
equivalent and then last but not least
you have your six hundredths so plus so
that's our ones that's our tents and
they're not wearing a hundreds place and
we're gonna have six of them so this
would be equal to our original value but
that's not what they wrote over here
they did write eight ones they did write
seven tenths but they did not write six
hundredths here they wrote six thousands
here so we can rule that one out and
then if we were to write it out in words
we would say this is eight eight and
I'll do and in a neutral color now you
might say and seven tenths and six
hundredths or you could often what's
normally is you express it in the the
lowest place that you have or the most
the most precise place that you have so
you could view seven tenths as 70
hundredths or you could view you could
view this whole thing as seventy six
hundredths so it could be eight and
seventy seventy six hundreds hundreds
but what they wrote over here they did
write eight but instead of seventy six
hundredths they wrote eight and sixty
seven hundredths a little tricky so we
would rule that one out as well